kevin hart posted this photo along with
the caption coming to ellen's defense
because everyone was talking about how
ellen has created this toxic environment
within her workplace
and she's thinking about stepping down
from the show he came out and basically
said that
he has always had great interactions
with her and her team
and he just wanted to defend his friend
he got a lot of [ __ ] for it made a
follow-up video
really he got he got in trouble for that
yeah because people were saying oh well
if you're coming out to defend ellen
when so many people
have proof of her like being shitty why
didn't you come to nick cannon's defense
and then he said that uh just because
you guys don't see it doesn't mean i'm
not supporting my friends behind the
scenes
nick cannon was at my house that entire
week when he got cancelled and yeah
but nick canning said some anti-semitic
you know racist [ __ ] yeah ellen's
running a show and her staff supposing
their staff
had a toxic environment and by the way
all
completely unsubstantiated nick cannon
we have a video of we can
refuse to apologize i this whole ellen
thing
because some youtube star from somewhere
somewhere outside the u.s
i believe it was somewhere in
scandinavia girl said she was mean
someone came flew here and was on ellen
and she's like
i was expecting confetti and like a big
warm and they were
not said they were not that nice to me i
was like what grow up
we're gonna [ __ ] cancel ellen because
like youtube yeah you know what they're
gonna be a lot nicer to [ __ ] kevin
hart yeah than they are to you youtube
star that's how
it's [ __ ] the business suck my balls
best friend's bieber
you know it's like uh you know i'm not
defending her
you know i don't know but i i will say
this and i read this
this tweet it's funny this this kid who
moved to la three years or four years
ago put
uh two things in la i can guarantee you
you need a parking ticket and you hear a
story about ellen b and [ __ ] yeah
yeah and by the way
we've all i've heard it forever me too
and ever
and by the way guys but i don't know she
should be i worked for somebody named
chelsea handler
for years notoriously known for being
pretty difficult right
but here's the deal man like if you
asked me was she difficult
i would tell you no i would tell you she
was in a very high stress job
she was she's a type personality a type
personality she was employing hundreds
of people
she was the she was the only at that
time
woman in late night and there was a lot
of [ __ ] all the time
were there times where she was maybe
shorter than she had to be
yeah but what person who's in a high
stress job who is the leader
isn't at some points gonna be short and
at the end of the day
i enjoyed this was just me i enjoyed
working for somebody
that i was going to know that day
what type of mood are you with right
yeah i i want to know
what you think it's like i said with
with people who are anti-semitic just
let me know
i don't want the guessing yeah and i
respected that chelsea would say what
was on her mind and if it hurts your
feelings
grow the [ __ ] that's that's also why
she's in that position yes because she's
through what's happening
so yeah and also i think everyone's so
[ __ ]
overly sensitive and i know that's a
trite thing to say i'm not even talking
about cancelled culture and that's it
i'm talking about how these staffers are
like
and then she wasn't nice to me this and
was nice to me
you clearly have never had a normal
person job yeah
because i could go down the list first
first job i had was working in a garage
and my boss was sam rohemian this
[ __ ]
gnarly armenian dude who went through
his life was hell
yeah and he used to come into the gas
station he said hey come here come here
my friend yeah okay
come here you see that sign you say 76
unical you say
it's a piece of pie you get no peace
i get all peace okay so get [ __ ] back
out there
go pump your gas you get no peace no
peace no peace for you
and and and i was like 15 years old i
was like okay
yeah yeah yes yeah by the time i was 25
and some show booker wasn't exactly
[ __ ] warm to me i was like oh
well i guess it's yeah it is i didn't
need everybody to [ __ ] kiss my dick
that's life though right right i mean
the deal is this
is the difference by the way that what a
great job people are kissing your dick
uh let me play so because he got a bunch
of [ __ ] purposely to do this
he looks tired this social media [ __ ] is
getting out of hand
it is truly getting out of hand
from showing support to a friend
you know you get a you got a [ __ ]
roar of frustration from so many
calls phone going off the [ __ ] hook
i'm a friend as a friend if i have a
friend in trouble ever
i'm gonna do my best mary ellen stuck up
for him yeah during the oscars
people go what about nick that's your
[ __ ] friend where were you for nick
[Music]
because you didn't see it means that i
wasn't there for nick
sad times you [ __ ] living man [ __ ]
over my house every goddamn day
wow through [ __ ] i was the one to call
the president of the goddamn studios and
reached out to so many to try to see
what we can do to solve the situation
find a solution nick and myself talk
we vetted out the situation as friends
because i was there for my it's like i'm
trying my best to be there for all of
them
when did we lose sight of reality
it's a [ __ ] up time man it's a [ __ ]
up thomas here's the deal though right
though
the deal is like okay at the end of the
video he tries to cancel somebody
what the [ __ ] dude but also like if
if you're talking about sexual
harassment or or somebody making you
feel
unsafe for your work yeah i get it if
your boss is an [ __ ]
either quit or [ __ ] deal gary go back
to that picture go back to that
helen's staff did make some like
the staff did do some [ __ ] where they
should probably lose their job if you
look into it
where people felt uncomfortable and
there's some bullying and some
sexual [ __ ] i can tell you i don't know
ellen from anyone but i can tell you
this i know daytime television
she doesn't know what the [ __ ] going
on yeah she has so much on her plate
trying to get ready for the next guest
meeting with her writers trying to
changing on the ass she doesn't know
what's going on with the show bookers
she has no [ __ ] clue ask somebody
who's worked for dr phil
that dude i worked on the same lot as
that guy oh really
that dude man ask somebody who's worked
for dr phil
legit nightmare stories
like a giant legit very no-nonsense
nightmares
i've never had any nightmare steve
harvey too though but he steve harvey
you know his
his staff that like did you see when
that came out he had a whole thing
and if you've ever done a show you go
like people go this is
an [ __ ] but if you've ever done a
show like it makes sense he goes no
talking to me when i when i get on set
oh man when i'm walking down the hallway
don't ask me questions i don't need to
do it you can hear me
my uh topics on the show i guess no eye
contact doing a little weird but
it was just like for him for but my
takeaway from the small thing i've done
tv and host my own show
it's all about your energy too and your
mental space and your energy and not
wasting on making sure every single one
of your employees is happy
does the guy who's who cleans
the garage at the tesla dealership
does he expect elon musk to return his
emails
you know what i mean does he expect him
to come down and be nice to him because
that's what we're talking about
the boss go back to the hedge
i had a personal interaction with dr
phil nothing bad but he's put his hands
on it he's no nonsense man both of them
i met with his son who
runs uh a lot of his production stuff
like logan's buddy and um
and he i had a meeting with him to
potentially host some show
and i'm in this meeting with with dr
phil's son very nice guy very we're like
shooting the [ __ ] he's like smiling is
he bald no i don't
just trying to sit down i don't remember
he's trying to set the table you should
go bald captain then
his dad just walks in and it hits him
he's huge
he's [ __ ] huge he's bigger than you
he's a big [ __ ]
doctor feels huge he's here to see him
and he just comes in and completely
stops the conversation
and starts talking to me like nothing
his son was saying would
matter and he goes uh nice to meet you
and he introduced himself
and uh then just starts talking straight
business no smiles no anything and i'm
like
oh that's a guy no i'm not saying this
is a negative i'm just saying that guy
the guy's a no-nonsense dude but you're
like
i think this is the real problem look at
celtic tiger 22's comment at the bottom
doesn't levitate above the rest of us
she should be
she should be hell sins accountable for
her
sins exactly okay so but also itself
people tiger 22
exactly but but there are people out
there lots of people who
look at being a dick boss
as a sin that you need to be held
accountable for
that's a real problem all this come you
know we're like god what happened with
everybody
well you're giving every dummy a voice
with social media
every dummy out there has a voice on
social media in it
dude so you're getting these crazy
opinions these people probably shouldn't
be telling you their opinion but i also
think
it starts really young so
you know my dad was telling me he said
you know the difference between
a major difference between your
generation and my generation i said
what's that
and he said you know when we went into
school for a parent teacher conference
and if you had a c we would
me and the teacher would be on the same
side be like what is wrong
how can we get your grades up why are
you getting a c
now you know who's responsible
the teacher now it's the parent because
my dad worked in education for so long
now the parent and the child are like
why are you giving me a c all right
what's wrong with you that you're giving
my kid a c wow so there's no
accountability
at all and a lot of it is coming from
the parents you know
when jacob was he had this teacher he
didn't like in high school
and he was like i don't like him let's
get me out of class and i said no dude
yeah
you're gonna have bosses you don't like
through it dude you don't you're gonna
bosses you don't like you're gonna
have people of landlords you don't like
you have to deal with it you have to
figure out how to still
do your job or run your life i'm not
gonna come in and save you from every
situation because then
you're gonna have zero problem solving
so this person yeah you're right
wants somebody else to solve the problem
but i also think
also too with social media like there's
a lot of mentally
ill people out there men and then also
with the society and such unrest and
you know unemployment and the pandemic
everything like everyone's so angry and
then this ellen news comes out and was
like yeah get her yeah cause they're
just so they're unhappy with their own
life so it's like yeah let's [ __ ] get
them man a lot of people
are unhappy i want them to be on yeah
there's a lot of records but
you didn't take the risk and you don't
have the talent of an ellen
so don't you're unhappy because what the
cards you were dealt or
the chances you never took so you want
to lash out at ellen or
kevin hart for sticking up for it or
whoever is in the limelight
do you think some people feel i don't
betrayed is the right word
but do you think some people feel
betrayed by her persona
and then the stories that they're
hearing that they feel like
she's been lying
doesn't matter though like lance
armstrong dude agreed
you know how many [ __ ] people with
cancer that he helped with this
livestrong
his positives so oh my god his name he
was taking steroids everybody was
and so for people to vilify [ __ ] this
guy i'm like do you understand the
foundation
and the awareness he brought to cancer
it doesn't matter the image
image let me give you a perfect example
letterman leno
that was the big right you know the late
night guys and they were two completely
polar opposite guys
when you heard something about jay leno
not being a nice personable person
it was it was earth-shattering because
he said
everybody's best friend yeah and and
from what i understand from columbus
from corolla who is really close with
jay like jay is that guy he'll take your
phone call personally he doesn't need
letterman never hid the fact he was kind
of a curmudgeon
he didn't and so he let you know so he
already
he established same i'm sure very
similar to chelsea handler it's not like
a story coming out like chelsea handler
was mean to me people be like oh yeah
well
everybody knows that you signed up for
it and there's a there's a real purity
to that because there's no hypocrisy you
know people on ellen thought they'd be
dancing ellen ellen comes out she does
her dance and everything and i think she
play portrays this everybody's best
friend so there is a big letdown i think
you know to a lot by the way
i think that's why joey diaz we talked
about this
didn't get canceled because he's shown
you every wart
and hiccup he's ever made in his life he
went to prison for kids
right so he so when this thing came out
about him
he was like yeah okay whatever
you know who i am i've done even if this
even if you're upset about this i've
done
way worse in my life you come from it
and so there was no
nobody felt like they were being tricked
you're gonna get what you ordered yeah
like you're not tricking with something
else you know exactly what you're gonna
get yeah you can
you almost there's a little bit of that
with trump too like in the understanding
of the election
in 2016 all these things that would
a normal politician they'd be like oh
god we gotta pivot and get
trump's like uh this woman's coming this
porn starts coming forward saying you
you had an affair with her yeah she's a
dog face what do i care you're like
oh we can't this guy's teflon you can't
you know what he was gonna [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you it's so crazy and so i
i think it creates
a pretty protective layer because you're
not surprised anymore yeah the shitty
says like all right
it's so weird though like what the [ __ ]
dude dude you know what you're 80. in
the elections when that was happening
and marco rubio
started to come out and take jabs it was
funny trump could say whatever he wanted
marco rubio came out with two insults to
trump people like you're better than
this
yeah and i was like because you're
exactly right yeah that's not who he
established
his character to be so we hadn't given
him the okay
people buy into it and and like the
people who have whether it be politics
whether it be music whether it be comedy
any any facet of
an industry where you live your life in
public authenticity
to me has always been the most valuable
characteristic because
people will always try to give that to
an audience but if people can sincerely
smell
authenticity they don't care what you do
agree they just know that you're giving
you're literally giving them to you
yeah you're right i bet you if ellen
comes back on here she's [ __ ] dick
yeah it was like god
take it down a
pulling pranks with their guests
by the way behind the scenes it's like
her being nicer
but when i get off stage at the lab
factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son